[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about whatever we love we
talk about how Blake Griffin's paying
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
month in child support that's a [ __ ]
time cuz the last one that I saw was a
Terrell Owens I feel on MTV they shared
that he paid seventy thousand seventy
thousand a month a lot people don't even
make that in a year man and this is two
hundred fifty thousand a month yeah
that's a lot man
how much does he make though a year cuz
that could be pennies well he's making I
think he's like 35 mil a season which is
a lot is still two to three million
dollars for someone that's not doing
jack it's okay so for me I feel like you
kinda deserves this right cuz it's like
how how long has like this been like
going on right like we're NBA stars or
just athletes they hook up with the
chick they break up and weaving YouTube
stars I have the same problem Oh chicks
is trying to get after me all the time
nobody pulls out anymore huh yeah what
the [ __ ] I do is don't think it the
compensation is fair like my thing is
like if you help that man Blake Griffin
build his empire then you [ __ ]
deserve that money you know never get a
women like I go on stage I talk about
that about like I it's just ridiculous
how much it's okay to get knocked up now
it's like it's literally okay to hook up
with a famous guy and try to get knocked
up that's like socially acceptable well
in what way because they're getting paid
for it like the legal things gold dick
it like you could literally like all mad
that's like a famous guy I'm gonna try
to get pregnant by him and sighs like
yeah that's totally okay that makes
sense you know
wait what society like you like movies
like use that trope there's like that
that ballplayer yeah and then there's
that true
yeah and it's cool for that to happen
but if in the movie if you had like a
dog [ __ ] yeah that was the protagonist
that would not be okay people would ban
would avoid a boycott this movie but if
you have
about a girl that's like I just want to
land Blake Griffin I just want to land
the Bron James that people okay I always
saw it as people looking down on women
like that you can all boycott the movie
it's like they they go yeah there's like
the negative it's kind of like oh that's
that's not right but that's as far as it
goes but yeah like treacherous and
villainous yeah and it's villainous cuz
you are trapping somebody and you're
using a baby yeah you're using a baby
for personal gain that's the [ __ ] you're
bringing a life into this world but then
they're just a business logic for a man
and they're getting rewarded for it yes
the products that you mean so like if
you're telling me right now like they
should be punished for it it's kind of
like you did this you popped out a kid
all for the sake of you know trapping
some wine you think it's in the gray
area too because then now they are the
mother of that child yeah but no but
this is not great it's not her intention
okay stop the same side at the same time
how come you guys even proved or how can
anyone prove that that was like what was
trying to happen like she was right and
beyond that to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars is way beyond the
normal means of for a family to live in
yes I'll say that but then why are we
going after the chip which I'm not on
the chicks that Mason sounds like you
are talking about the ones that are self
proclaimed I'm gonna [ __ ] a ball player
yeah [ __ ] them and their [ __ ] shits
to society for sure but why are we going
after the [ __ ] lawyers you know what
I mean like it's totally the lawyer
that's putting up this [ __ ] contract
but it's not the Lord it's it's lock
helpful to get a certain percentage yeah
full-california yeah should go after
these forever the governor
even if you do a prenup in California it
doesn't fly oh really because they go
based off of what they've become
accustomed to living like yeah if
they're married and stuff like that and
it's like oh if you've been married for
what 20 30 Mary's oh no they didn't get
they were about to get married Blake
Griffin and listen I'm a clipper fan and
the Blake Griffin story is just so sad
because yeah many change the franchise
and that I love him to death he got
super Hollywood and he's it's game fell
off man and he just he they were about
to get married and then he meant a
Jenner these Kardashians are just
wrecking rappers and black athletes
right the man's fault if you really
think about it right right well I'd
always the guy's fault do women do
anything bad because guys are expected
to be above women that's why I mean if
you want to see it that way you can
gonna at least be on par like be up to
par you know what I mean like be equals
to us because you guys get played
[ __ ] easily like how all it is is
power the [ __ ] news don't like me
really okay that's why we're like we're
so easily played like a five-year-old at
a daycare yeah teacher you can at least
take care of us that'd be so awesome but
you guys already know about we're
inferior that's it biologically we
cannot step up yeah absolutely but you
guys are so dumb we let you we trap you
with your money haters are not working
for you and the society still okay with
that that's the problem because it's
really run by women and you guys don't
even run society yeah
what are you guys are you guys gonna
like jump in I told you biologically
that's what it is and then there's no
cookie there should be no complacent
goddess better than right that's what it
is so sad dude as your dick runs the
show until you like do you overthrow the
dictator but up to that moment you can't
think dude yeah when you get like you're
like nah this is a bad decision but it's
like bit late yeah I bet you there's so
many dudes out there that was like [ __ ]
I was just trying to get my nut off why
why oh and there's Lonzo ball who just
like he's one year to leak are to get
married Ari has a kid family [ __ ] them
I'm sorry for your ball fan but yeah
that dad [ __ ] those kids up well look
at those haircuts they are you like a
big boy yeah weird like I would have
it's so interesting because you see all
their kids and they all look weird I do
look weird huh they don't look black
they don't look white they just never
even look athletic yeah that's a great
point
Lonzo ball he looks like he looks like
Frankenstein's creature dude I'm
surprised that their performance cuz it
didn't they look like the kid I would
never pass the ball to you yeah well
their dad just [ __ ] that I mean Lanza
ball is demonized cuz his dad's is a
crazy person he's actually a really
great basketball player and he never
talks [ __ ] he's super quiet and like
everybody just beats him like a pinata
cuz his dad's a crazy person Lonzo oh no
his brother Luigi or whatever his name
nobody gives a [ __ ] of a hug yeah they
went to China and they like don't [ __ ]
with the Chinese homeboy
I had floor seats at a Clippers game
right and I just saw like how much were
they like $2 point free this is this is
what we're banging dude like only until
recently but like [ __ ] it's so weird
when you see basketball up front that
close oh yeah cuz you don't realize how
[ __ ] athletic these guys are yeah
it's because I literally saw it like cp3
go from one end to the other end like in
two seconds you know
like how [ __ ] fast are these humans
look or looks [ __ ] tiny yeah and the
people don't even realize like they're
like why the [ __ ] did people get out the
way when they're dunking cuz when you
see somebody like tank boy Griffon fly
yeah yeah it's like a car flipped over
in a high-speed chase and is going in
the air it's [ __ ] wild and you see cp3
on TV you're like look at that a little
[ __ ] right there but if you walked if
you like that dude is Jack any six foot
one yeah there's a big dude but Barry
looks like it a little tiny man it's
like everyone else is the same height so
it seems like they're all regular it's
like yeah we even like the announcer
like even if it's a chick host or
whatever then she's [ __ ] tall to us
so then you're just like oh wait this is
walk off have you seen the Dodger chick
that does all the sideline report she
looked she's wonderful she loves
baseball man but she's so tall that
they've um you could find pictures of
the players happen to stand on a bucket
because so they look down and like I
don't know that's her call or their call
but they literally stand on a Chase
Utley and like it's standing a bucket
that's fun the cameraman because
anything to have to be this way yeah why
don't they do that so we're like even
till this day like for how many years
Blake Griffin has been in the league
like I love that guy man he's a super
nice dude he is great like that
[ __ ] still cannot dribble a
[ __ ] ball [ __ ] is that about you know
what happened to him specifically is
like his athleticism comes so far right
but now like there's athletes now that
has his athleticism but they can dribble
a ball they know how to stay in the
pocket they can smash him now so it's
like it sucks you know what I mean
because even watching I'm just like dude
learn to dribble he wants to be LeBron
James and he's not he doesn't have that
skill set I wish he could just work on
or maybe he just can't do it like I'm
weirdest thing is he's like clearly the
only player I know that's dad was a
coach and he can't shoot like every
coach's son Kelly he's like assassin
from everyone he's the only guy I know
that like can't shoot he's gotten way
better he's at least worked on his game
but it's like it's really weird and
towards like the last couple seasons of
him in the Clippers what's with the
[ __ ] three-point shooting [ __ ] you
know I mean like why the [ __ ] are you
shooting threes dude that's always been
doing it towards the last couple seasons
he would like back it up I try to shoot
cuz he doesn't like to get hit but
that's your game dude like you're a big
dude and you go down the mill like a
bull in china shop and he just doesn't
like to get hit man down everybody
thinks the NBA's touch but man
everyone's like touch blood touch dude
those guys are committing felonies out
there man that's why these euros come
here and they can't play because they
don't play against quality black
athletes they just [ __ ] them up man
damn from a distance though it doesn't
seem that aggressive well it's not to
prove the NBA where you'd literally get
mugged back like in like the 80s yeah
cuz you know like how when we play like
pick a ball we play really really really
soft so if we play a pickup game like
with random people you're getting shoved
your pelvis your bruises are pushing off
you when they do they trying to cross
you cuz you know it's very competitive
like that that's why it's like playing
with friends cuz it doesn't it's not
like that but when you play pickup games
people are like trying to cross and
they'll shove you off you know that's
how it is yeah that's like playing all
in a Dean but I when I watch a game they
don't highlight what's happening to the
other players around well you know it's
it's mainly just the the closest thing
that you would see is like a dude do a
layup or something and he gets like kind
of clothesline or he gets hit time but
they would like commit almost like
murder on people's reminds like the
[ __ ] Michael Jordan days and the
frickin Bulls and like that [ __ ] I used
to feel that that was way crazier energy
yeah but I was a kid back then too I
didn't look at the game the same way but
now does it just it's like a technical
game or I don't know it just doesn't
seem as action flopping there's just
yeah I mean you see soccer e-everything
the technical foul nowadays yeah I
remember when [ __ ] shot just swung
his arm back in knockout Vlade students
it was a wild did [ __ ] Dominic
Wilkins Shawn Kemp all these
[ __ ] they were aggressive as
[ __ ] Wow boom get the [ __ ] out
you know if it was so tight have you
played it
No thank God that's why he's still alive
and injured free I mean I mean I shot
the bobble I don't play like pickup
games anymore just cuz it's too
dangerous
did you [ __ ] up both your ankles yeah
just--we're actually both my ankles so
once that's in college and once with
these guys yeah I used to play I just I
just think I'm too slow now man I used
to be a 3d guy I hold school like I just
no no way up rules I just thought I'd
follow the [ __ ] outta you dude those
days are done I just I can't do it I
Romanian way though yeah we used to play
[ __ ] pick-up games at the park and
the minute the Armenians come inside do
is put on the football plan cuz they're
playing [ __ ] they're playing basketball
and sweaters and track suits right in
dress shoes they play basketball billing
which night you bring today huh which
knife path meatball it's like rugby the
best balls of [ __ ] rough sport man it
was so funny because my mom didn't want
me to play I thought you were about to
say your mom played that would have been
doe like she didn't want me to play
football so I wouldn't get hurt so I
played basketball and I fractured both
my ankles that's crazy
you can always tell like if like it's
very interesting we talk about pro
athletes not you people you could always
tell great the athlete it is by how I
flick the mother is like if the mom is a
li athlete that guy's gonna be crazy
athletic like usually especially
track-and-field like when the mom ran
tracks right the kid is always suit like
and andrew wiggins mother was like this
super track person like a dad played in
the NBA she was a track star so the kid
can kill Blake Griffin's mom was like a
deep I think d1 basketball or volleyball
player so that kid is gonna be able to
jump out of the like the gym dude it's
called epigenetics he likes what what
epigenetics that sounds like something
you do you put somebody when they're
having like a seizure something
no I just depends on the state that the
moms like the physical state that the
moms in which is pregnant with their
kids really such a beef guys so like
depending on so everyone has the gene
for being skinny buff fat whatever like
everyone has genes for like any type of
physical expression that you see but
depending on what state you're in some
markers are activated or not and then
when you conceive a child
those are the ones that you're passing
on really yeah so when you have care
when some of them are skinny some of
them are fat some or whatever and if you
self-reflect you can be like oh [ __ ]
that was the phase of life that I was in
so your sperm is like like if you're fat
then it's gonna be fat sperm yeah your
[ __ ] bust that bourbon or this test
was like for Hugh yeah and so then now
your baby's fat you're like why go I
wasn't my fat phase when I was like four
obese dudes and they check the sperm and
all the markers for ADHD was on there
for obesity was on for a lower cognitive
thinking was on all four dudes they lost
horrible lower cognitive thinking ADHD
and [ __ ] fatness that's a dumpster
fire and then those four dudes they lost
weight those four dudes they lost weight
and then the ADHD marker got turned off
and the kids were gonna have normal
metabolism and everything unbelieva
weird it's all simulation dude it's all
just some weird ass [ __ ] out there ADHD
is linked to the OBC yeah wow I've never
seen a super hyper fat person that's
what I'm saying I'm like this is so
counterintuitive maybe they can't like
focus or some [ __ ] I don't know like a
focus that was easy though because I'd
be [ __ ] on that [ __ ] dude focus on
the sandwich and the french fry and the
shake and the dessert whoa oh wow that's
right
oh do you know that I know no oh yeah
that's someday maybe we'll see I don't
know a like if I'm in the right place
but then I think like the world's going
to [ __ ] you know I want bring these kids
yeah I just adopt the kid and teach them
how to be a ninja [ __ ] like I think
about that all the time do I want to
bring kid into like cuz it just seems
like it's maybe it's just the news or
maybe this is always everybody thinks
they live in the worst time ever yeah
over time we've thought that but it just
seems like it's getting bad and do you
want bring kids into this we're like you
could jeez just see an environmental
collapse and then they just have to like
live in the streets and haunt write book
a you like totally man I don't think
about any of that you that I'm just like
this not much blasting hey my problem
finding friends for the rest of our life
I do follow this page on Instagram I
think it's called like human progress or
something like that but they basically
show you objective and stats of things
that are happening like realistically
right now that's positive
so like Austin yeah because it's like
there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
news right - kind of just scare you or
whatever but they're like actually we we
haven't seen this long of like world
peace in a long time like it's always
been some kind of massive war or or
genocide going around like in the in
history that's what I heard that like
statistically the world is actually way
better than it ever was but it's just
the news is counter to that oh yeah
everybody's depressed all the time
they're on all this medication because
they just watch television it's just
like beach down beach down in particular
women man you watch like how
psychologically television just tries to
shish-kebab woman's brain yeah like you
ever watch a commercial [ __ ] snake
just [ __ ] with your skull like never
watch a commercial where like the mom
seems like 2 years older than her kids
the
so yeah so they're expected to be
beautiful
they're expects to be career driven
while having like all the mom duties
yeah it's like in and if all if one of
these things don't fit then they're not
woman enough or they're not good it is
it's [ __ ] crazy so one of they're
like insecure all the [ __ ] time about
everything and you never know so like
when like let's say a man driven
entertainment right they know this one
is gonna be so big that women they're
gonna watch it the programming is a
little different and it's all meant to
like emotionally get a response like
everything's about making women cry all
the time
be emotional like just spat it's like
really it's all psychological they just
make you super overly emotional like
when you watch like the Super Bowl right
don't always have some story like little
Timmy or you know beat this and beat
that it's all mental psychologically
just [ __ ] [ __ ] with their brains like
American Idol yeah every single one is a
sob story like oh what's what happened
to this singer yeah like I was a capable
book at home I'm also refugee and I had
to [ __ ] fight for my food or
something like you know once he Bob
being like hey dude nothing's really bad
my life I just I know how to sing I can
sing like a month it's not a dream to
say all these sob stories are always
comedy to me it's always funny have some
sad a story and then afterwards they
sing [ __ ] like the thong song
[Laughter]
I'm sort of big of a party about a
thousand and [ __ ] I do
[Music]
you